* Spannungsgeladene Klänge,
Uhrticken *
Vor 40 Jahren haben
diese zwei Bankdirektoren erreicht,
was als unmöglich galt:
Sie halfen,
den Inbegriff der Schweiz zu retten:
die Uhrenindustrie.
Am meisten belastet
hat mich eigentlich,
dass es immer wieder hiess,
man müsse sofort
eine Sitzung mit den Banken machen.
Dann hatten alle den Kalender voll
und man musste am Abend
um 20 Uhr nach Egerkingen.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge,
Uhrticken *
Es war eine enorm belastende Phase.
Was passiert wäre,
wenn wir das nicht gemacht hätten?
Dann würde die Schweiz
anders aussehen als heute.
Eine ganze Region wäre am Boden.
Und zwar
lange Zeit am Boden geblieben.
Es ging auch um mehrere
Zehntausende Arbeitsplätze.
Insgesamt 80'000 oder 90'000,
mit all den Zulieferbetrieben.
Es war die grösste und wichtigste
Rettungsaktion einer Industrie.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge,
Uhrticken *
Es war: Vogel, friss oder stirb.
Wenn das Abkommen
nicht zustande gekommen wäre,
wäre unsere Uhrenindustrie
verschwunden.
* Tippgeräusche *
Es wäre eine Katastrophe gewesen
für die Schweiz.
* Tippgeräusche *
Salut. Ca va?
* Tippgeräusche,
sanfte Streichklänge *
Heute blüht
die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie -
auch dank des Uhrenpioniers
Jean-Claude Biver:
Das ist ein neues Werk,
es heisst MECA-10.
Es ist
in einer neuen blauen Keramikfarbe.
Das ist eine unglaubliche Harmonie.
Voila, die würde ich kaufen.
Schweizer Uhren
dominieren den Weltmarkt.
* Tippgeräusche,
sanfte Streichklänge *
Heute ist sie stark wie nie zuvor,
heute sind wir
stärker wie nie zuvor.
Erfolgreich
dank einer jahrzehntealten Tradition.
Die mechanische Uhr ist Kultur,
Tradition, Kunst und sie ist ewig.
In 100 Jahren wird sie noch laufen.
Und das ist das,
was die Leute heute schätzen.
Sie wollen nicht mehr
mit der Obsoleszenz zu tun haben.
Sie wollen sich
an die Ewigkeit anknüpfen.
Wir brauchen Ewigkeit,
wir haben ja keine mehr.
Und das ist ein Grund,
weshalb wir heute so erfolgreich
sind mit der mechanischen Uhr.
40 Jahre vorher.
(Protestrufe) Bulova, solidarite!
Bulova, solidarite!
Krise, Resignation,
Hoffnungslosigkeit.
Die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
vor dem Aus.
Man weiss nie: Muss ich jetzt gehen
oder muss ich nicht gehen?
Das Alter spielt dann
auch eine Rolle,
ob man moralisch zum Teufel geht.
Sie beginnen einen Beruf, und
fast jeden Morgen wissen Sie nicht,
ob Sie am nächsten Tag noch
weiterarbeiten können oder nicht.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ich habe gerne hier gearbeitet.
Wir Angestellten lebten damals
in einer völlig unsicheren Welt.
Wir machten uns alle grosse Sorgen.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Wenn man schon jahrelang
in einem Betrieb gearbeitet hat
und sein Herz gegeben hat ...
... und dann die Kündigung erhält,
das ist verrückt für einen Menschen.
Ich weiss nicht.
36 Jahre habe ich mich
für das Geschäft hingegeben.
* Melancholische Klänge *
(Mann) Im Moment ist es für uns
wie ein schwarzes Loch.
Alle fragen sich:
"Was kann ich tun?"
"Wohin kann ich gehen?
Muss ich diese Region verlassen?"
Und da wir fast alle hier in diesen
Bergen und Tälern geboren sind,
möchten wir natürlich hierbleiben.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Es war ein Schiff,
das in einem riesigen Sturm stand,
und alle hatten Angst,
alle wollten vom Schiff runter.
Kein Mensch war in der Lage,
zu sagen: "Kommt, Kinder!"
"Das Schiff kentert,
wir haben riesige Wellen."
"Eventuell sterben wir alle, aber
wir sterben wenigstens wie Männer."
"Wir bringen dieses Schiff
unter Kontrolle und schauen,
was wir daraus machen können."
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ich wusste ganz genau:
Wenn wir in der Schweiz
ein Produkt herstellen können,
eine Uhr mit weniger als 7 oder 10 %
direktem Lohnkostenanteil,
können wir alle anderen schlagen.
Die Swatch -
der eine Ausweg aus der Krise:
Wir haben in unserem Studio
die zwei Swatch-Väter, die Erfinder,
Monsieur Jacques Muller
und Monsieur Elmar Mock.
Die Begeisterung
von zwei jungen Ingenieuren damals,
Herr Mock,
in Kunststoffen spezialisiert,
und ich, seit über zehn Jahren
in Uhrwerken spezialisiert -
diese Begegnung
von zwei Welten kreierte die Swatch.
Voila.
So lautet die Zusammenfassung.
Wissen Sie,
im Leben benötigt man Chancen.
Man muss sie natürlich
auch ergreifen.
Das ist kurz gesagt
die Geburt der berühmten Swatch-Uhr.
* Sanfte Streichklänge *
Jean-Claude Biver - er wählt
in der Krise einen anderen Ausweg:
Es war eine Tragödie.
Ich hab's ... Es war ein Schmerz.
Ich habe es aber auf der anderen
Seite auch als gut erlebt,
denn ich habe profitiert.
Um plötzlich in diesem Wechsel,
in dem alles
nur um die Zukunft ging ...
Nur Zukunft.
Wir verlassen die Vergangenheit,
wir brechen sie, werfen sie weg:
keine mechanischen Uhren mehr,
nur Quarz.
Zukunft, Zukunft.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Da gibt es auch einen Weg
rückwärts, innovativ zu werden."
Heute weiss er,
dass er richtig entschieden hat:
Das sind sehr gute Ergebnisse.
Plus 32 % gegenüber dem Vorjahr,
das ist schon erfreulich.
Ich bin sehr zufrieden.
Das sind gute Nachrichten. Von Zeit
zu Zeit muss man die auch mitteilen.
Okay, a tout a l'heure, Thomas.
Mitten in der Krise kauft Jean-Claude
Biver eine alte Traditionsmarke -
für ein Butterbrot.
Als niemand mehr an das Überleben
der Uhrenindustrie glaubt,
hat er eine Vision:
Wir beschäftigen uns
schon mit der Ewigkeit.
Und Ewigkeit ist ... Was ist ewig?
Liebe ist ewig.
Die Kunst ist ewig.
Picasso kann nicht sterben.
Mozart kann nicht sterben.
Die Beatles
können auch nicht sterben.
D.h., das war unsere Idee.
* Sanfte Streichklänge *
All you need is love.
Wir haben uns gesagt:
"Voila, die Liebe ist ewig."
Aber nicht nur
die Liebe zwischen zwei Menschen.
Liebe ist eine moralische Attitüde.
Und dann ... Ich hatte natürlich
eine Leidenschaft für Uhren.
Was ist in den Uhren ewig?
Nicht Quarz!
Wir wussten das.
Denn in dieser Zeit wurden die
Batterien immer schmaler, kleiner.
Und natürlich konnte man
die Batterien nach zehn Jahren
nicht mehr kaufen,
weil sie kleiner wurden.
Plötzlich waren die Batterien
nicht mehr aus Quecksilber,
sondern aus Lithium.
Dann wurde Lithium verboten.
Das haben wir alles gesehen,
und wir haben das alle gewusst.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Da haben wir immer drauf gespielt:
Ewigkeit.
Eine mechanische Uhr ist ewig.
Es ist das Kind
eines Heritage, eines Erbes,
das Kind einer Tradition,
es ist das Kind einer Kunst.
Kunst, Luxus, Erfolg - vor 40 Jahren
in dieser Krise unvorstellbar.
Diese Wiedergeburt der
mechanischen Uhr in dieser Masse,
das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Ein bisschen schon,
denn mit Blancpain
haben wir das ja gemacht,
aber dass plötzlich alle Marken
wieder
mit mechanischen Uhren kommen,
das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Keiner hätte das gedacht.
Sonst hätten wir
die Werkzeuge nicht weggeworfen.
Denn in den 80er-Jahren
haben wir so sehr gedacht,
dass das nie wiederkommt,
dass wir alles weggeschmissen haben.
Wir haben keine Werkzeuge behalten,
die meisten wurden weg...
Niemand hätte gedacht,
dass das zurückkommt.
Die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie.
Sie beherrscht jahrzehntelang
den Weltmarkt:
95 % aller verkauften Uhren
stammen Anfang des 20. Jh.
aus der Schweiz.
Hergestellt in den Juratälern.
Lange Zeit eine Erfolgsgeschichte.
Die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
zu Beginn des 20. Jh.,
vor und nach dem Ersten Weltkrieg,
dominiert absolut den Weltmarkt.
Es gibt Konkurrenten in den USA,
in Frankreich, noch nicht in Japan.
Aber die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
dominiert den Weltmarkt total.
Die Schweizer Uhrenmacher haben
Angst, diesen Vorsprung zu verlieren.
Damit die ausländische Konkurrenz
nicht von ihrem Wissen profitieren
kann, erlässt der Bundesrat Gesetze.
Er verbietet den Export
von Uhrenbestandteilen,
alles wird geregelt:
Wer wann wo in welcher Menge
produziert - alles Gesetz.
Quasi eine Planwirtschaft.
* Spannungsgeladene Chilloutklänge *
Anfangs geht alles gut:
Die Uhrenindustrie, organisiert
in Klein- und Kleinstbetriebe,
floriert
dank staatlich geregeltem Schutz.
* Dynamische Klänge *
Und so realisiert sie nicht,
dass ein Sturm aufzieht.
Denn die japanische Uhrenindustrie
hat mittlerweile
die Schweizer Uhren kopiert.
Und sie produziert hocheffizient.
Roboter ersetzen die Handmontage.
Japan produziert zentralisiert,
nicht zersplittert in Kleinstbetriebe
wie in der Schweiz.
Ernüchtert damals
das Schweizer Fernsehen:
(Originalton) Dieser Apparat,
der die Zeiger anpresst,
ist über 40 Jahre alt.
Die museumswürdigen Maschinen
werden immer noch
bei der Schalenfertigung eingesetzt.
* Schnelles Ticken, Klirren *
* Klirren *
Man hat gesehen, wie die Umsätze
ständig gefallen sind.
Dass die Umsätze
mal nach oben gehen ...
Schwankungen sind im Leben normal,
aber hier ... bam, bam, bam.
Gleichzeitig löst die Erdölkrise
eine weltweite Rezession aus.
Und die nächste Krise
folgt gleich danach:
die Währungskrise.
Der Franken schnellt in die Höhe.
Je te prends
5 Mio. de dollars avec 0,1.
Die Schweizer Uhren
sind plötzlich doppelt so teuer.
Sie werden
aus dem Markt katapultiert.
In den USA, im damals
wichtigsten Markt für Uhren,
werden die japanischen Uhren
plötzlich günstiger
als die schweizerischen,
die extrem teuer sind.
Der Faktor Währung ist sehr wichtig.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Ich hörte, es soll nicht gut sein,
wegen dem Franken.
Was das nächste Jahr bringt,
wissen wir noch nicht.
Ich merke es auf der Strasse,
wenn man mit den Leuten spricht:
Jeder hat etwas Angst,
es könnte zu Entlassungen kommen.
Fast jeden Morgen wissen Sie nicht,
ob Sie überhaupt zur Arbeit
zurückkehren können oder nicht.
Es gab viele Entlassungen.
So habe ich es damals erlebt.
Nicht im Finanzbereich,
ich war ja Ingenieur.
Ich habe
eine enorme Verunsicherung erlebt.
Und das war ziemlich belastend
für einen jungen Familienvater.
* Dynamische Anfangsmelodie *
(Originalton) Grüezi miteinander.
Die schweizerische Uhrenindustrie
hat bekanntlich
ihre führende Stellung
auf dem Weltmarkt eingebüsst.
Dadurch sind in den letzten
13 Jahren in der Schweiz
rund 50'000 Arbeitsplätze in
dieser Branche verloren gegangen.
* Protestrufe, Trommeln *
(Alle) Bulova, occupe, solidarite!
(Alle) Bulova doit vivre!
Wir sind diejenigen, die heute quasi
nur noch für den Misteimer gut sind.
Das ist das, was die Herren wollen.
Das erwarten sie von uns,
wenn wir den Mund halten.
(Mann) Die allgemeine
Wirtschaftslage zwingt uns,
Rationalisierungsmassnahmen
durchzuführen, wo immer wir können.
Der Transfer von Neuenburg nach Biel
dient dazu, Kosten zu sparen,
zu vermeiden,
dass wir in Biel und in Neuenburg
nicht voll ausgelastete
Fabriken haben.
Dadurch wollen wir wieder
konkurrenzfähiger werden.
Die härteste Konkurrenz:
japanische Uhren.
Sie werden maschinell produziert,
sind viel günstiger
und qualitativ gut.
Sie finden reissenden Absatz.
(Originalton) Innert fünf Jahren hat
sich Japans Produktion verdoppelt.
Der Ausstoss der Schweizer Firmen
hingegen stagnierte.
(Biver) Wir haben gespürt,
dass das Flugzeug an Höhe verlor.
Und wir wussten,
dass es nur eine Lösung gibt.
Wenn ein Flugzeug an Höhe verliert,
muss es nach unten,
damit es wieder Schwung bekommt
und es die Luft unter den Flügeln
wieder tragen kann,
damit es über den Hügel kommt.
Wir wussten, dass die Lösung
vom Sparen kommen würde.
Aber nicht nur vom Sparen,
sondern auch vom Reorganisieren
und von neuen Innovationen.
Und zu spüren ...
Wissen Sie, das ist
eine ganz schlimme Atmosphäre,
wenn man arbeitet und jeden Tag
mit denselben Problemen
konfrontiert wird:
Ich verkaufe nicht genügend.
Ich bekomme nicht genügend Umsatz
in die Kasse rein.
(Mann) Allors,
travailleurs, travailleuses ...
* Melancholische Klänge *
Was wir gerade durchmachen,
kommt mir vor
wie ein langsames Ausbluten.
Es ist wie die "Abschiedssymphonie"
von Haydn, die wir spielen.
Wir machen noch Musik,
aber es klingt nicht mehr voll.
Kein Mensch
hat mit so etwas gerechnet.
In dieser Krisenzeit
sitzen die beiden Bankdirektoren
in Verwaltungsräten der Uhren-
industrie und beobachten das Drama.
Unsere Kontakte ...
- Die von uns beiden?
Ich hätte Tagebuch führen sollen.
Die ganze Weltwirtschaft
war in einer schwierigen Situation.
Es gab Ölkrisen.
Der Dollar war abgewertet worden
von 4.30 Fr. auf 1.50 Fr.
Und dann
ist gegen Ende der 70er-Jahre
die japanische Uhrenindustrie
massiv aufgetreten
mit ihren billigen Quarzuhren.
* Tippgeräusche,
spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Die Quarzkrise - der nächste Schlag:
Japan wirft zu dieser Zeit
die elektronische Uhr auf den Markt.
Eine Revolution in der Branche. Die
Schweiz gerät weiter in Rückstand.
* Rhythmische Klänge im Werbevideo *
* Ein Mann spricht japanisch. *
Man darf nicht vergessen,
bis 1975 oder 1977,
sag ich jetzt mal,
war die Präzision
ein Qualitätsbeweis.
Je präziser die Uhr war,
desto teurer war sie auch.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Plötzlich kommt eine japanische
Firma, z.B. Seiko, mit einem Preis,
der 70 % tiefer liegt,
aber eine bessere Präzision hat.
Natürlich ist es keine mechanische
Uhr, es ist eine Quarzuhr.
Die Leute sagten sich aber:
"Oh, präzise, präzise."
Also haben die Japaner es
irgendwie erreicht, unser Konzept,
das auf Präzision gebaut war,
total zu zerstören.
Weil sie
mit relativ günstigen Produkten
eine bessere Qualität bzw.
Präzision hatten als die teureren.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge,
Uhrticken *
(Originalton) Die Zeitquelle
ist dieser Quarzstab.
Er schwingt
über 32'000-mal pro Sekunde
und wird
von einer Kleinstbatterie gespeist.
Hier nun das revolutionär Neue:
So sehen integrierte Schaltkreise
unter dem Elektronenmikroskop aus.
Sie wandeln
die Schwingungen des Quarzstabs um
und addieren sie zu Sekunden,
Minuten, Stunden und Tagen.
Zwar fertigt
die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
die erste serienmässige Quarzuhr,
die Beta-21,
doch mit dem Verkauf hapert's.
Die Schweizer
wissen ebenso gut wie -
wenn nicht besser als die Japaner -,
wie man Quarzuhren herstellt.
Aber die Japaner
sind besser in der Vermarktung -
darin, etwas zu produzieren,
das sich verkaufen lässt.
Die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
produziert am Markt vorbei.
Die Warenlager füllen sich
mit unverkäuflichen Uhren.
Originalton damals im "Kassensturz":
Auf den Champs-Elysees
kaufe man die besten Uhren,
sagte uns ein Taxichauffeur.
Wir fanden da aber
keinen einzigen Omega-Laden,
dafür ein grosses Seiko-Center.
In den Schaufenstern
keine Ladenhüter,
sondern nur neueste Modelle.
Ladenhüter hingegen
sind die Schweizer Uhren.
Massive Rabatte sind notwendig.
Swiss made ist kein Wert mehr.
Hören Sie, man sagt,
das menschliche Wesen
beginne erst dann nachzudenken,
wenn es sich in der Not befinde.
In dieser totalen Unsicherheit
in der Uhrenindustrie
müssen Sie reagieren und
sich fragen, was man tun kann.
So war das Klima damals.
Klar, nachher gibt es
10'000 Versionen darüber,
wer der Patron war,
der befahl, eine Uhr zu entwickeln,
die nichts kostet und von Schweizer
Qualität ist. Das ist nicht wichtig.
Wichtig ist, dass sich eine
kleine Equipe an die Arbeit machte.
Sie überlegte, wie man dieses Ziel,
diesen Traum einer Schweizer Uhr,
die nichts kostet,
verwirklichen könnte.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge,
Uhrticken *
Noch gibt es einzig Prototypen
mit vielen Kinderkrankheiten.
Doch Mullers Equipe
kann weiterforschen.
Das ist ein Schlüsselprodukt,
um die Märkte der Industrieländer
anzugreifen.
Viele, viele Ingenieure
haben sich auf
die mechanischen Uhren konzentriert.
An diese Welt
glaubten wir Jungen nicht mehr.
Wir glaubten, diese Welt sei tot.
Für uns waren das Dampflokomotiven
verglichen mit dem TGV.
Voila. Wir wollten nicht mehr
mit Dampflokomotiven arbeiten.
So war die Lage damals,
in den 80er-Jahren.
ASUAG -
so heisst damals der eine Konzern,
der die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
dominiert.
SSIH der andere. Beide sind am Ende.
(Originalton) Freitag, 28. Februar.
Die Belegschaft wird kurzfristig
auf den späten Nachmittag
zur Betriebsversammlung geladen.
Kurzarbeit
für 13'500 Arbeitnehmer bei ASUAG.
Es ging also sehr schnell.
Es ist schon schlimm,
denn jetzt ist es einfach endgültig.
(Mann) Das wirtschaftliche Klima ist
etwa zwei Kutten kälter geworden.
Wenn sie aber meinen,
wir würden dabei erfrieren,
haben sie sich getäuscht.
Man weiss genau, alles wird teurer,
die Steuern
muss man dennoch bezahlen.
Das Brot und alles,
die Butter, alles wird teurer.
Ich fürchte,
es ist nicht das letzte Mal,
dass wir euch aufrufen müssen, zu
kommen, um zu zeigen, wer wir sind,
wie viele wir sind
und was wir eigentlich wollen.
Die beiden Bankdirektoren
erinnern sich.
* Uhrticken,
spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Du hast ja schon im Jahre 1981
intensiv an der Sanierung der SSIH
arbeiten müssen.
Und du hattest das ganze Prozedere
eigentlich schon erlebt,
das wir dann ein Jahr später
bei der ASUAG eingeleitet haben.
Das ist richtig.
Ich kann mich auch daran erinnern,
dass ich,
als ich bei der SSIH begonnen habe,
meine Agenda genommen
und geschaut habe:
Wo könnte ich mich jetzt freiboxen,
wie wenn ich einen Beinbruch
oder etwas Ähnliches hätte?
Ich war dann aber
angenehm überrascht,
dass ich
relativ viel freimachen konnte.
Ohne Schaden für die Bank?
- Das weiss ich nicht.
Aber es ist doch einiges möglich,
wenn man muss.
(Biver) Die SSIH hatte kein Geld,
um alleine weiterzugehen.
Wir hatten
echte Probleme mit dem Umsatz,
mit der Liquidität
und sogar mit der Industrie.
Also ...
Die SSIH musste meiner Ansicht nach
gerettet werden.
Sehr viele Arbeitsplätze
stehen auf dem Spiel.
SSIH beschäftigt ca. 4'000 Leute.
Angefangen hat es so:
Wir sollten dringend
einen Überbrückungskredit
zur Verfügung stellen.
Die SSIH ist nicht im Stande,
die Dezemberlöhne
vor Weihnachten zu bezahlen,
sonst geht sie pleite.
Kurz darauf schlägt auch ASUAG-
Präsident Peter Renggli Alarm.
* Tippgeräusche *
Im Herbst hiess es plötzlich:
"Wir brauchen Geld, 185 Mio."
Und dann waren die
relativ schnell investiert.
Oder verbraucht.
* Tippgeräusche,
melancholische Klänge *
Dr. Renggli hat damals
sogar noch wörtlich geschrieben:
"Zunehmender Preiszerfall,
die Japaner überschwemmen
den Weltmarkt mit billigen,
sehr genauen, aber ziemlich
hässlichen Quarzuhrwerken."
Dann hat mir Herr Frehner gesagt:
"Du, die ASUAG
ist auch in Schieflage."
Und dann haben wir gesagt:
"Wir hätten gerne
einen Steuerungsausschuss."
Weil wir gesehen haben:
Wir müssen langsam eingreifen.
Wir können nicht einfach zuschauen,
wie dieses Management weitergeht.
Obwohl sie
ein paar Sachen unternommen haben,
die ganz gut und richtig waren.
Aber wir haben gefunden:
Das wird nie reichen,
um eine Katastrophe zu verhindern.
Und wir sagten Dr. Renggli:
"Jetzt müssen wir vorwärtsmachen."
"Jetzt muss etwas gehen."
"Und wir Banken schlagen vor, dass
man jetzt die Firma Hayek engagiert,
eine Studie zu machen."
"Eine Crash-Studie, die innerhalb
von sechs Monaten aufzeigt:
Ist diese Firma noch zu retten?"
(Originalton) Nicolas G. Hayek
wurde als Sohn eines Zahnarztes
in Beirut im Libanon geboren.
Seine Grundausbildung erhielt er an
einer französischen Jesuitenschulen.
Anschliessend studierte Herr Hayek
am Centre d'etudes mathematiques
et physiques der Universität Lyon,
wo er mit dem
certificat de licence
in Mathematik, Physik
und Chemie abschloss.
Herr Hayek, Sie wurden Berater.
Was haben Sie dort angetroffen?
Eine riesige Menge Erwartungen,
dass der liebe Gott uns hilft,
und eine totale Arroganz
gegenüber andere Menschen:
"Wir sind besser,
weil unser Urgrossvater
die besseren Uhren gemacht hat."
Totale Verkenntnis der Mentalität
all unserer Kunden im Ausland,
das habe ich angetroffen.
Er war auch
an unser Treffen in Interlaken
im Januar 1982 eingeladen.
- In Interlaken.
Das war übrigens
eine chaotische Diskussion.
Du hast die geleitet,
ganz hervorragend,
aber du hast die Diskussion
laufen lassen.
Das ging kreuz und quer,
und ich kann mich daran erinnern,
dass wir uns
mehr als einmal verrannt
und nicht mehr gewusst haben,
wie es weiterging.
Dann hat Peter gesagt:
"Halt! De quoi s'agit-il?"
"Worum geht es?"
Wir haben ein System angewendet,
bei dem wir sagten:
"A-Marken sind Omega und Longines."
"B-Marken sind Mido, Tissot etc."
"Und C-Marken,
das ist die aufkommende Swatch."
Wie heissen die Papierständer,
die wir hatten?
Flipcharts.
Ja, dann konnten wir
wieder weitergehen.
Und dann haben wir uns gefragt:
"Welche Organisationsstruktur
geben wir dem?"
Es gibt drei Varianten.
Eine ist mini.
Der sagte man Eiger.
Die Variante midi,
der sagte man Jungfrau.
Und eine Variante maxi,
das war die Variante Mönch.
Mönch - alles unter einer Kutte.
Die Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
war verzettelt.
Jede Marke war für sich alleine, die
meisten gehörten auch Privatleuten.
Dann kam der grosse Hayek-Plan,
der sagte:
"Wir müssen alle unter ein Dach."
"Wenn wir alle diese Marken und
Lieferanten unter ein Dach bringen,
dann haben wir Stärke
und natürlich auch die Mengen."
"Dann können wir auch industriell
etwas gegen die Japaner tun."
Dort ist am Schluss -
nach diesen zwei Tagen -
in präziseren Umrissen
herausgekommen,
was man nachher gemacht hat.
Aber viele Details
mussten wir nachher klären.
Damals hätte niemand auch nur 5 Rp.
gewettet, dass das gelingt.
Am Schluss, für die definitive Zu-
stimmung zu diesem Sanierungspaket,
hatte ich
im Verwaltungsrat Widerstand
von den grossen Industrievertretern.
Und ich musste kämpfen,
damit die zustimmen.
Und die haben einfach gesagt,
dass die Strategie,
die wir da angedacht hatten,
eine schwammige Sache sei.
"Und im Übrigen habt ihr ja
gar keine Chance gegen die Japaner."
Jean-Pierre Bonny leitete damals
das Staatssekretariat für Wirtschaft
SECO.
(Originalton)
Mit welchem Gefühl gehen Sie
zur Verwaltungsratssitzung?
- Ganz realistisch.
Aber auch mit Herzblut?
- Ich war engagiert.
Was geschieht, ist mir nicht egal.
Bonny hat als Bundesvertreter
das Drama persönlich miterlebt.
Damals schrieb er
eine Geheimnotiz an den Bundesrat.
Da musste ich
die Alarmglocken läuten.
* Tippgeräusche,
spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Ich habe dann
sogar in einer Notiz geschrieben,
das sei wie
Vogel friss oder stirb.
Es war also entscheidend,
dass die Übung gelingt.
Daraus entstand dann die ganze
Fusion zwischen ASUAG und SSIH.
Was wäre passiert,
wenn die Übung nicht gelungen wäre?
Dann wäre die Uhrenindustrie
aus der Schweiz verschwunden.
Es wäre nichts mehr übrig geblieben.
* Uhrticken,
spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(Originalton)
Heute und jetzt geht es darum,
dass die Banken einen Betrag
von 116 Mio. abschreiben müssen.
(Reporter) So sachlich und nüchtern
tönte es heute
an der Pressekonferenz,
an der die Bankenvertreter doch
einen sensationellen Beschluss
bekannt gaben. Guten Abend.
Sensationell ist, dass Hunderte
von Millionen von den Banken
zur Verfügung gestellt werden, damit
die Sanierung überhaupt gelingt.
Und sensationell,
weil die Fusion von ASUAG und SSIH
doch einen Uhrengiganten schafft,
der mit den Grössten Japans
jetzt konkurrenzfähig sein wird.
Die Banken zusammen,
das war fast ein Wunder,
dass das zustande gekommen ist.
Schlussendlich über 100 Banken
unter einen Hut zu bringen
und sie
mehr oder weniger zu überreden
oder zu zwingen, mitzumachen.
Die Banken haben die Firma gerettet,
beide Firmen gerettet.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
Dr. Gross, wie beurteilen Sie die
mittelfristigen Zukunftsaussichten?
Eher optimistisch,
auch wenn der Weg noch lang ist.
Wird das was bringen?
Es sollte etwas bringen,
ganz sicher.
Was stellen Sie sich vor?
Auf jeden Fall
keinen Abbau von Arbeitsplätzen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass dies etwas
bringt, für uns Arbeiter nicht.
Wir rechnen nicht damit,
dass in nächster Zeit
oder auf mittlere Frist
grössere Betriebsschliessungen
noch notwendig sind.
Management abbauen -
glauben Sie, das bringt etwas?
Wenn sie das machen würden,
würde das was bringen, ja.
Selbstverständlich müssen
in allen Organisationseinheiten
noch Dinge optimiert werden,
was hier und da noch zu geringen
Abbaumassnahmen führen könnte.
Die Banken
sind mit sehr viel Engagement,
mit sehr viel Geld eingestiegen.
In der Meinung,
dass man das dann wieder
in industrielle Hände überführen
oder in einem breiten Publikum
platzieren kann.
Und im Mövenpick Restaurant
hat Herr Hayek gesagt,
er habe privat 60 Mio.
und die Börse sei nicht seine Sache.
Peter Gross hat mich eines
schönen Tages angerufen und gesagt:
"Du,
Hayek ist eventuell interessiert."
"Wir sollten darüber sprechen."
Und dann haben wir uns getroffen
und er hat mir erklärt,
wie diese Idee
zustande gekommen war.
Und ich fand:
"Ja, das sollten wir machen."
* Hoffnungsvolle Streichklänge *
Ich glaube an das Ungewöhnliche,
an das Wunder.
Ich habe
bei der Uhrenindustrie geglaubt,
dass ein Wunder passieren kann.
Ich bin kein Pessimist, der sagt:
"Das geht nicht mehr."
"Fertig, hören wir auf!"
Ich bin wie ein Kind:
voller Hoffnung,
voller Träume, voller Vorstellungen.
(Reporter) Hinter dieser Fassade
an der Dreikönigstrasse 21,
mitten im Finanzplatz Zürich,
wurden wichtige Entscheide
in Sachen Uhrenindustrie gefällt.
Heute wurde in einem Telex bekannt,
dass unter der Führung
von Nicolas Hayek
51 % der Aktien des Uhrenkonzern
den Besitzer gewechselt haben.
Kritiker sagen,
die Banken hätten es Herrn Hayek
als Schnäppchen verkauft.
Aus heutiger Sicht
kann man Ja sagen.
Aber damals gar nicht.
Man wusste ja nicht,
ob die Sache gelingen
oder wie sie weitergehen würde.
Aus heutiger Sicht
ist es ein günstiges Angebot,
und aus damaliger Sicht
war es ein faires Angebot.
Aber es war kein Geschenk.
* Old School Hip-Hop *
* Uhrticken *
Gilbert.
- Bonjour.
Ca va?
- Oui et vous?
Bonjour.
- Allez-vous m'avancer?
Schauen Sie, die ganze Mannschaft
hat Tag und Nacht gearbeitet.
Schauen Sie, wie viel Spass ihnen
ihre Arbeit bereitet: Sie lachen.
Vous parlez Schweizerdeutsch?
- Pas du tout.
Vous devez avoir honte.
* Lachen *
* Old School Hip-Hop *
Ich glaube an das, was ich mache.
Und dann kann ich das übertragen.
Die Menschen um mich herum
glauben auch daran und machen mit.
Das reisst mich nicht vom Stuhl.
Das reisst mich
wirklich nicht vom Stuhl.
Er hat für Atlanta
viel schönere Sachen gemacht.
Das ist nichts.
Diese Kinder ...
Es fehlt das gewisse Etwas.
(Frau) Diese zwei Uhren
wurden nach den Wünschen
des amerikanischen Marktes gemacht.
Die haben keinen Geschmack
in Amerika, verdammt noch mal.
(Mann) Hat Martin sie
mit seinen Kindern getestet?
Das kommt viel ...
Wieso sind wir hier,
wenn sie nicht okay sind?
Abgelehnt,
ich möchte die richtige Uhr sehen!
So ist die nicht zu verkaufen.
Das ist eine total langweilige Uhr.
Kinder, da ist ja nichts dran.
* Old School Hip-Hop *
Ich brauche
ein Produkt im unteren Marktsegment,
damit ich
gegen die Japaner kämpfen kann.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(Muller)
Als Ingenieure waren wir sicher,
und das stimmt wohl auch:
Wir haben
ein perfektes Produkt kreiert.
Und ich glaube, auch heute sind die
Menschen zufrieden mit der Swatch,
die gut läuft und wenig kostet.
Ein gutes Produkt zu haben,
ist eines.
Es zu verkaufen, ist etwas anderes.
Und Erfolg zu haben,
nochmals etwas anderes.
Ich sage zu Hause immer:
"Ich kann eine gute Suppe kochen,
aber damit Erfolg, Renommee
zu haben, das schaffe ich nicht."
Und ich kann mich ganz gut erinnern,
dass wir damals gesehen haben,
dass die Swatch als technisches
Wunder nicht zu erklären ist.
Das Publikum im Ausland
hat überhaupt kein Interesse daran,
wie viele Teile sie
in einer Uhr haben.
Sie wollen eine schöne Uhr,
die funktioniert.
Daraufhin haben wir gewusst:
Wir müssen dieser Uhr
eine Seele geben.
Und da haben wir der Swatch
eine Seele, eine Botschaft gegeben.
* Spannungsgeladene Klänge *
(Donze) Die Uhr ist nicht mehr
ein Produkt, das die Zeit anzeigt,
sondern ein Modeartikel.
Es ist das erste Mal in der Schweiz,
dass man einen Modeartikel
für die breite Masse hat.
Und so verkauft man sie auch.
Es ist in der Uhrenindustrie
der Beginn des story tellings.
Die Uhr dient als Mittel,
um Geschichten zu erzählen.
Eine Geschichte für das Publikum,
für die Journalisten und andere,
eine Geschichte,
die über die Uhr hinausgeht.
Eine Swatch ist nicht mehr
eine Uhr, die die Zeit anzeigt,
sondern etwas Cooles, Sportliches -
und gestützt darauf
beginnt man zu kommunizieren.
Herr Hayek hat sicher
das Potenzial der Swatch gespürt.
Deshalb hat er auch seine eigenen
finanziellen Mittel investiert.
Er hat daran geglaubt.
Diese Marke hat er immer
gegenüber anderen bevorzugt.
Das ist auch heute
bei seinem Sohn der Fall,
der, natürlich wie ich,
diese Marke bevorzugt.
Warum habe ich
mit Swatch angefangen?
Wir hatten
90 Fabriken mit 6'000 Arbeitern,
die gar keine Arbeit hatten -
um Biel und Neuchatel herum.
D.h., ich hätte
keine Alternative gehabt,
ausser diese zu schliessen.
Und das gesamte Know-how
der Schweiz zu verlieren.
Wenn wir aber
eine Uhr lancieren würden,
die mehr als 100'000, 200'000
oder 300'000 pro Jahr verkauft,
die in die Millionen geht -
das haben wir gehofft -,
dann retten wir diese Fabriken.
So haben wir es gemacht.
We'll be right back to discuss this.
Ladies and gentleman, I'm talking
to one of the great entrepreneurs
in the western world:
Nicolas Hayek, president of Swatch.
Ich habe selten einen Menschen
mit einer derartig
raschen Auffassungsgabe gesehen.
Mit einer
derartigen Kombinationsgabe.
Es gab Sitzungen, da hat er,
kaum wurde ein Papier verteilt ...
Ich denke
an den Steuerungsausschuss ASUAG.
Sitzungen mit vielen Zahlen.
Ich glaube,
ich bin auch nicht der Langsamste,
aber kaum lag ein Papier
auf dem Tisch des Einzelnen,
sah er, dass etwas nicht stimmte.
Sie haben es sich
nicht mal angesehen, verdammt!
Man kann die kleinsten Hindernisse
nicht mehr überwinden,
wenn man sie sich
nicht vorher ansieht.
Zwei Techniker hier sagen,
er könne das, und Sie sagen Nein.
Das sagte ich nicht.
Mit dieser Linie zum Polieren,
das geht nicht.
Das rundet alles ab.
- Das sind ...
Jacques, vous etes serieux.
Vous allez me faire
un petit chargement
pour qu'ils puissent la polir.
Welches ist Ihre grosse Schwäche?
Ich bin sehr ungeduldig.
Wahrscheinlich
auch ungeduldig im Geschäft.
Ich habe keine Geduld
mit liebevollen, netten Menschen,
die sehr viel Zeit brauchen,
um etwas zu verstehen.
Ich habe keine Geduld mit
dem Piloten, bei dem ich denke,
dass er gleich gegen den Berg
fliegt. Den ersetze ich sofort.
Wenn grosse Gefahr besteht
für mein Flugzeug.
Ähm ...
Wissen Sie, wenn Sie
kreativ, innovativ, lernfähig
und neugierig sind,
dann gehen Sie ja
immer nur nach vorne.
Es gibt nur den Weg nach vorne.
Nicolas Hayek
setzt nicht nur auf die Swatch.
Zusammen mit Jean-Claude Biver
forciert er auch
die teuren mechanischen Uhren.
Das wird
der zweite Weg aus der Krise.
Wer kauft eine Uhr für 1 Mio. Fr.?
Unter uns, nicht ich,
aber da gibt es viele.
Das ist eine Übertreibung, oder?
- 30 Stück.
Wir haben aber 30 Stück verkauft.
Das sind 30 Mio. Fr.
Wir haben natürlich
den Plan von Hayek gesehen,
die Effizienz und die unglaubliche
Meisteridee von Hayek, zu sagen:
"Ich muss zuerst das untere Segment
wieder stark machen,
damit ich eine starke Basis bekomme,
damit ich im niedrigen Preissegment
die Anzahl, die Quantität habe,
um dann darauf die Pyramide
bis ganz nach oben zu bauen."
Das hat natürlich
nicht gleich jeder verstanden,
aber es war
eine absolut geniale Idee.
Das Foto von Herrn Biver
kostet 1'000 Fr,
das von Boris Becker 5'000,
das von mir 500 Fr.
Können Sie näher zusammenstehen?
Die Kunst geht weiter, indem sie
die Vergangenheit nach vorne bringt.
Und das ist die Ewigkeit.
Und wir haben gesagt, dass wir
eine ökologische Uhr machen.
Und eine ökologische Uhr ist eine,
die keine Elektronik besitzt.
Und die sich
nur mit dem Handgelenk aufzieht.
Das ist ja ein Wunder.
Das ist ein Wunderwerk.
Das ist ja
die beste Erfindung, die es gibt.
Mit meinem Körper, der sich bewegt,
bringe ich Energie in das Objekt.
Was wollen Sie Besseres?
Das war unsere Leidenschaft.
Und darauf haben wir immer gesetzt:
Ewigkeit.
Die mechanische Uhr ist ewig.
* Sanfte Streichklänge *
Seine Vision
ermöglicht die Renaissance
der Schweizer Uhrenindustrie.
Es ist so, es ist die Wahrheit,
sie ist stärker denn je.
Weniger Uhren, dafür aber teurere.
Japanische Uhren sind heute auf dem
Weltmarkt praktisch bedeutungslos.
Heute kennt die Uhrenbranche
das Potenzial des Marketings.
Es ist nicht mehr
eine Frage der Industrie,
sondern man muss
die Uhren verkaufen können,
ihnen mit einer guten Markenpolitik
einen Wert hinzufügen
und sich nicht einzig
auf diesen hervorragenden restruk-
turierten Industrieapparat stützen,
sondern auf die Marken,
die diesen nutzen.
Das industrielle Problem ist gelöst,
man bewegt sich jetzt hin
zum nächsten Problem,
zum Wertzuwachs
via einer Markenpolitik.
Dort stehen wir jetzt,
und dieses Muster hat sich bewährt
und der Schweizer Uhrenindustrie
erlaubt,
ihre kompetitive Position
zu stärken.
Im Jahr 2010 stirbt Nicolas G. Hayek.
Seinen Nachkommen
hat er bereits zu Lebzeiten
Führungsaufgaben übertragen.
Sie kontrollieren mit dem sog.
Hayek-Pool die Swatch Gruppe.
Seine Kinder
leiten heute das Unternehmen.
Seit der Machtübernahme der Familie
Hayek über die Swatch Gruppe
leben wir ...
Sicher, man muss arbeiten,
Neues entwickeln.
Aber was die Arbeitsmoral
und die Sicherheit
des Arbeitsplatzes betrifft,
so leben wir im Paradies
seit ihrer Ankunft.
Das ist unbestreitbar.
(Frehner) Wir waren unserer
Verantwortung weitgehend enthoben.
Das war positiv.
Wir haben immer gesagt:
"Wir geben das
möglichst schnell in andere Hände."
Als Banker konnten wir
auf Dauer keine Uhrenfirma führen.
(Gross) Richtig.
Deshalb waren wir froh,
dass das dann passieren konnte.
Bei Swatch
ging es natürlich auch darum:
Sie hat den Glauben
wieder zurückgegeben, durch:
"Wir,
die schweizerische Uhrenindustrie,
spezifisch die Swatch Group,
wir können das."
V.a. gegenüber den Japanern
war es ein gelungener Streich.
Die waren völlig baff,
dass aus der Ruine etwas kommt,
das neuer und besser ist,
als das, was sie gemacht haben.
Eine billige, neue, geschmackvoll
designte Uhr ist rausgekommen.
Das hatten sie nicht,
und sie haben es auch nie geschafft,
auch nur annähernd
etwas Ähnliches zu machen.
* Sanfte Streichklänge *
Zuerst haben die Japaner uns
mit ihrer Quarzindustrie zerstört.
Sie haben die mechanische Uhr
kaputt geschlagen.
Wir kamen mit dem Hayek-Plan zurück
und sagten:
"Wir machen auch Quarz,
Schweizer Quarz, aber zu 50 Fr."
Das war die Swatch,
die hat dann die Japaner zerstört.
Und später kamen wir wieder zurück
mit der mechanischen Uhr.
Und heute ist die mechanische Uhr
der King
der Schweizer Uhrenindustrie.